and the poll just came out and I'm tied
with Jeb Bush and I said oh that's too
bad how can I be tied with this guy he's
terrible he's terrible you've heard him
on television you've seen him on the
Internet
he's so many places how can you keep
track you couldn't until now introducing
Donald Trump's Greatest Hits June 2015
to August 2015
old Donald you need and one small 16
disc DVD compilation featuring work from
such classic rants as immigration I will
build a great great wall on our southern
border and I will have Mexico pay for
that wall war hero he's a war hero
because he was captured I like people
that weren't captured okay I hate to
tell you and little arrivals your
senator what a stiff
what is him Lindsey Graham not to
mention a bevy of his top charges our
leaders are stupid our politicians are
stupid I'm really rich I'll show you
that ISM I beat China all the time what
just got begger
somebody's doing the raping done I mean
who's doing the raping act now and
you'll receive the bonus you're a loser
just absolutely free they're losers just
losers but there's more we'll even throw
an exclusive clip from his first and
only debate you've called women you
don't like fat pigs dogs slobs and
disgusting animals your Twitter account
only Rosie O'Donnell
he's prolific he's bombastic and he
could be yours America and by that I
mean your president seriously he's
pulling very well
[Music]